hey folks welcome to reality check so
Skylanders now I've always known it was
popular hell they can be hard to avoid
with all the advertising and the stacks
you see when you walk into a game store
but it wasn't until I looked into some
Activision financials recently that
realized just how popular they are the
franchise alone is worth 3 billion
dollars Skylanders trap team is the
top-selling kids video game in the world
and the reaction figures well they sold
more than any other top action figure
line worldwide for the third year in a
row now this got me thinking what is it
that makes Skylanders so popular now
don't get me wrong the games themselves
are good in their own right but the Key
has got to be those damn adorable we
figures you see our innate human
psychology pre programs us to like
adorable things as the ever fantastic
Vsauce explains in his video why are
things cute there are certain
characteristics which lead us to find
things totes adorbs and they are all
characteristics we find in babies so
small body size big head mode and
rounded features so do we see these
characteristics in our Skylanders while
this little chap is named food fight and
he quite clearly takes all three of the
baby similar boxes plus he's got this
wicked tomato launcher in fact I think
you'd be hard-pressed to find any
Skylander who doesn't have at least two
of these traits now the reason we are
drawn to these baby like characteristics
makes a lot of sense from an
evolutionary standpoint the human
species you see is in a much better
place if human parents are
unconditionally motivated to care for
their offspring scientific studies using
functional MRI scans of test subjects
brains have shown that by simply looking
at cute pictures of babies you actually
activate pleasure centers in your brain
interestingly I reckon this knowledge is
not lost on Activision as last year as
part of their most recent entry in the
franchise trap team they launched
special mini versions of some of the
most popular characters very clever I
mean look at mini Spyro
yeah but you know our innate fondness
for all things cute is not the only
trait of human psychology the skylanders
takes advantage of now everyone knows
humans love to collect things sometimes
a little too much we've seen it happen
time and time again like the Cabbage
Patch right in the early 80s the Furby
fad and the pursuit of all things
Pokemon in the late 90s the list goes on
Skylanders is just one of the latest in
toy crazies and it's so profitable
because it has so many adorable we
fellows to collect in a previous episode
of reality check I touched them on a
couple of reasons why we love to collect
games specifically you can watch that
video here but the basics are that we do
it for a number of reasons like wanting
to preserve a collection and not by
giving things up we actually cause
ourselves pain but perhaps there's more
to it than that some theories concerning
collecting believe that merely gathering
these items satisfies us on a deep
emotional level yes some of this does
stem from our good friend Freud and yes
apparently this is a result of
unresolved toilet training the idea
being that we don't like to lose
anything like anything like a me but
aside though as kids we form bonds with
inanimate objects like a comfort blanket
or a favorite teddy bear we feel safe in
the presence of these things on over
time we become used to the idea of
holding on to you and amassing these
material possessions because we
associate them with positive feelings of
safety and security taking this one step
further with Skylanders then the only do
we get the gameplay benefits by owning
more and more of the toys we get the
emotional benefits of amassing a
collection that we are bonded with as a
collection grows we gain happiness from
adding to it reorganizing the display
hunting down elusive items and of course
sharing our experiences with other
people so there's way more to this than
just trying to regain control of your
bowels thanks Freud your weirdo so tell
me what do you guys think of Skylanders
do you find them collectible unadorned
let me know in the comments down below
and as ever you can reach out to me on
twitter at camfrog
well thanks for watching